very interesting data about acceptance
of homosexuality in the u.s. among some
different groups and we've talked quite
a bit about attitudes for Muslims around
the world towards homosexuality and
there's major cause for concern there no
doubt but I want to talk about attitude
specifically within the United States
Pew Research has put out a new study and
the study finds that American Muslims
are more accepting of homosexuality than
white evangelical Christians in the
United States since 2007 American
Muslims have increased their acceptance
of homosexuality from 27% to 52% that is
almost doubled meanwhile white
evangelical Christians have also
increased acceptance of homosexuality
but way less from 23 percent to only 34
percent in 2016 which is the most recent
year we have data for and you know that
on this program my desire is to follow
the facts right if evidence points to
female genital mutilation being a
problem in Muslim communities around the
world I will tell you that I have told
you that and I've gotten slammed by some
people for that if most Terror around
the world is perpetrated by Muslims I
will tell you that and I've told you
that and many people don't like it and
along the same lines if most terror in
the United States is committed by white
non-muslim men as it is I will tell you
that and many hatreds haven't like that
and a common argument against American
Muslims is they don't assimilate they
don't mesh with our values the truth
though is that our country has become
more and more accepting of homosexuality
the American Muslim community has
doubled its acceptance of homosexuality
but it's the white evangelical
Christians that are lagging behind in
terms of accepting the direction the
country is going as a whole that's the
data that's the data and here's the
really interesting part that I want to
talk about this study asserts that
persecution of Muslims after 9/11 in the
u.s. has shown them why it's wrong to
minimum marginalize other minorities
like LGBTQ individuals that sometimes
works and sometimes it doesn't and I've
been thinking well do we have examples
either corroborating or
parting from that into the Jewish
community the Jewish community has been
one of the most persecuted in all of
history right kicked out of dozens of
countries over a period of thousands of
years endless persecution one of the
most progressive religious communities
today you put aside conservative Hasidic
Jews which are a tiny percentage of all
Jews and the Jewish community has worked
for the rights of all populations look
at the anti-defamation league as an
institution in favor of LGBT rights
african-american rights at any
opportunity would evangelical Christians
become more accepting of others and
defenders of other's rights if they were
persecuted I don't know because they
believe they are persecuted right
they've been talking about the war on
Christmas for a very long time and it's
not leading them to self-reflection that
makes them say let's stand up for Muslim
American rights let's stand up for LGBTQ
rights whatever so I don't know that
that works where if you are persecuted
you realize the importance of defending
all persecuted communities doesn't seem
to be happening with evangelical
Christians
well it's interesting how some
right-wingers make this argument that
homophobia within some segments of the
Muslim community is a rationale for you
know legislation that targets them or
say Trump's Muslim ban so I putting
aside the fact that since when are
conservatives champions for gay rights I
mean if that's your argument then I
guess white evangelicals should be
targeted too you would think so you
would think so and none of it adds up or
makes any sense and particularly
interesting I find this idea that you
can single out the Muslim American
community as particularly resistant to
assimilation when it's the evangelical
Christians that at least on this
particular issue are resisting the trend
and wave that we are seeing in the
United States I have no interest in
putting out there any assertions about
these issues that are not backed by data
I have no horse in this race and it's
really important to think about what the
impact is of these blanket statements
that we make check out the study we're
linking to it in the description to this
YouTube video for the story and you can
also send me your thoughts
about it on Twitter I'm on Twitter at
the D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
today's episode made possible by taga
dev the hosting specialist taga dev
offers a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options they also do custom
server solutions and colocation services
taga dev has a really user-friendly
interface and excellent customer support
team their expert hosting specialists
also are their friendly support team and
they give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud tag
Adad is offering you as a david pakman
show viewer or listener a twenty British
Pound free credits about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers signing up
to give you a chance to try their
services to take advantage of it
go to signup tag adapt calm /td PS for
more information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up tag adapt calm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS
20